llegó la hora de la información
económica aquí en directo a América en
France 24 pero yo me acompaña en el
estudio de mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido vamos a iniciar en Perú
porque las protestas como ya lo decíamos
continúan y están amenazando con
paralizar casi el 2% del suministro de
cobre a nivel mundial está en juego
Valentino unos 4.000 millones de dólares
en cobre y coincide también con un
aumento de la demanda por la reapertura
de China la tercera mayor mina de cobre
de Perú las bambas estás en operar desde
el 3 de enero por motivos de seguridad y
otra importante a tapacay tiene varias
restricciones ambas representan casi el
2% de la producción mundial de cobre las
protestas tras el arresto del
expresidente Pedro Castillo sacude en el
país afectando las cadenas de suministro
de materias primas que van desde los
metales hasta el café actualmente los
inventarios se encuentran en niveles
bajos y se prevé una mayor demanda del
metal con el auge de los vehículos
eléctricos los precios del Cobre tocaron
su nivel más alto en siete meses en la
bolsa de metales en Londres goldman sach
predice continuos déficit y pronostica
también un precio récord de 11.000
dólares la tonelada dentro de 12 meses
Jorge y en Francia más de un millón de
personas protestaron esto lo estábamos
diciendo en contra de las reformas de
las pensiones bueno estas
manifestaciones paralizaron parte del
transporte público también las escuelas
y la administración pública algunos
manifestantes se enfrentaron con la
policía el plan de pensiones elevaría la
edad de jubilación de 62 a 64 años un
techo que está entre los más bajos de
hecho de la Unión Europea y aumentaría
los años de cotización requeridos para
que para recibir una pensión completa de
aprobarse los franceses deberán trabajar
un mínimo de 43 años para obtener una
pensión completa a partir del 2027 y
aquellos que comenzaron a trabajar antes
de los 20 años accederán a una
jubilación anticipada sin reforma habría
un déficit aproximado de 13.500 millones
de euros y es por eso que el gobierno
quiere evitar las encuestas reflejan sí
que alrededor de dos tercios de los
franceses se oponen a aumentar la edad
de jubilación una medida que llega en
medio del aumento de los precios y
también con el país recuperándose de las
consecuencias económicas de la pandemia
Pues un panorama que no pinta tan bien
Vamos a Estados Unidos porque el
gobierno allí ya alcanzó su actual techo
de la deuda que es 31,4 billones de
dólares bueno el límite de dinero que
ese país puede pedir prestado legalmente
se ha elevado ya 78 veces desde el año
1960 la administración Ya toma medidas
como modificar las inversiones En dos
fondos gubernamentales para jubilados
quedará el tesoro cierto margen para
seguir haciendo pagos federales mientras
no pueda aumentar el nivel general de la
deuda las medidas incluyen suspender
hasta junio los pagos al fondo de
pensiones para trabajadores públicos que
no sean necesarios tampoco es la primera
vez que se toman medidas como esta desde
el año 1985 el organismo ha recurrido a
acciones similares más de una docena de
veces ahora el presidente Joe biden y el
congreso tienen hasta junio para llegar
a un acuerdo que eleve el techo legal de
endeudamiento de Estados Unidos Pese a
que se torna en una acalorada discusión
política la mayoría de veces se logra el
entendimiento Pues ojalá Ojalá así sea
Jorge y bueno no podemos dejar de lado
el foro económico mundial en que Cuál
fue el tema principal de esta jornada
sin duda alguna entre los temas más
relevantes estuvo la petición de greta
thunberg a la industria energética
mundial y a su financieros para poner
fin a todas las inversiones en
combustible fósiles algo que generó
reacciones como la del líder de la
oposición británica que era sterner
quien afirmó que no habrá inversiones En
nuevos yacimientos de petróleo y gas en
Reino Unido si su partido perfecto para
gobernar Colombia por su parte anunció
una cumbre de países amazónicos para
mayo la ministra brasileña de medio
ambiente Marina Silva aseguró que su
país pretende liderar la protección de
la amazonía y por Y ser ejemplo mundial
de ello la Unión Europea Ecuador Kenia y
Nueva Zelanda presentaron la coalición
de ministerios de comercio sobre el
clima esto con el objetivo de promover
políticas comerciales que sirvan para
combatir el cambio climático a la
iniciativa se sumaron casi todos los
miembros del g7 además de Ucrania
Colombia Costa Rica y Barbados bueno
Cuál es la cifra del día Jorge doce
millones de dólares eso perdió el
velocista olímpico usain bolt en un
millonario robo Los abogados el ocho
veces campeón olímpico afirmaron que
faltan 12,7 millones de dólares de su
cuenta en una empresa de inversiones de
Jamaica que está siendo investigada por
la policía y por el gobierno el dinero
dijeron era parte de la jubilación del
atleta Jorge tristes a usted muchas
gracias por esta ampliación económica
hasta la próxima continúa igual con
nosotros lo invito para que se quede
porque ya Seguimos aquí en directo
América con nuestra sección directo a
[Música]